the earth and the moon were born
together and they have dramatically
shaped each other's evolution now we
think that life was also given a head
start by the presence of our oversized
moon this is the earth 4.4 billion years
ago around the time scientists think
life on Earth got started
the newly-formed moon sits just 15,000
miles away appearing much larger in the
sky that it does today
it's gravity raises enormous tides in
the Earth's warm young oceans that era
the ties were not measured in feet
they were measured in miles you'd have
these massive tsunamis that would wash
up on land and then wash back into the
sea
the moon's gravity creates tides by
drawing Earth's oceans up toward it and
a bulge of water and as the Earth spins
this bulge washes onto land as a tide
the closer the moon the bigger the pull
of gravity and the stronger the tide
some scientists think that the warm rock
pools these giant early tides left
behind formed the perfect mixing bowl
for the ingredients of life to come
together the good thing about a titel
pond is that environments change water
comes in brings nutrients goes away the
nutrients concentrate so that may have
been a process that concentrated the
stuff life needed in a way that led to
life
4.4 billion years ago on rushing tides
stir up organic molecules from the
surface of the earth
as the tides recede these chemicals are
left behind in shallow rock pools which
then evaporate in the heat of the Sun
concentrating down their chemical
contents
perhaps the first life was born inside
this rich organic soup if we had tiny
little moons around the earth like Mars
does then we never would have had the
massive tides that carry materials and
energy up onto the beach environment
where life really might have gotten a
foothold and and so we wouldn't have had
the minerals who wouldn't have had the
energy and maybe we wouldn't have had
life did the moon create life on Earth
the jury's still out but one thing's for
certain intelligent life takes time to
evolve in our case at least 4 billion
years we've gradually changed from
simple single cells to the kind of
organism that can question its own
origins
and it's the moon that's provided the
stability for life to evolve by holding
the Earth's axial tilt steady for over 4
billion years